i want to know i'm so curious like
obviously you're a matrix fan obviously
you're a keanu fan and and lana like
everything about this movie i'm sure
you're a fan uh what day of the shoot
were you sort of sitting there on set
being like are you [ __ ] kidding me i
am in this movie like you know what i
mean
yeah no i had i had a few of those
moments
the first day seeing keanu in the
costume and hearing the voice that was
definitely a pinch me moment and then
also yahya and i had one where we were
on this rooftop of a of a skyscraper in
san francisco it's the middle of the
night
there's a helicopter swerving through
these skyscrapers and lana wachowski
holding the camera
leaning out of the helicopter we can't
hear a single thing
but i look over it
and i read his lips as he says we're in
the matrix and and i didn't need to hear
him i knew exactly what he meant like
this is one of those moments that
it's almost a greater experience in life
than it than it ever could be on the
screen
uh i'm a big fan of lana and i'm curious
what really surprised you working with
her that perhaps you weren't expecting i
mean i think everything was a surprise
like lana is quite mysterious she
doesn't do a lot of press like so i
didn't really know that much about her
process but it's this unique combination
of very fluid and then very specific
we get to set and
she kind of makes it up as she's going
along depending on the light and how she
feels that day but then it would come
down to lines where she would have
really specific notes
on on pronunciation and emphasis and
intonation
uh she really she really had the film in
her head i think
and and knew exactly what she wanted so
yeah i think that surprised me how
unique of a combination that was
you get to do some pretty cool action in
this movie on which day of the of the
shoot were you like this might be was
there any day that was just really above
and beyond in terms of challenging where
you're like this might be too much
yeah i'm afraid of heights and there's a
scene where
bugs
jumps off a building
and i did the jump in san francisco and
then the fall we were meant to shoot in
berlin
psyching myself up to do that
was painful
and everyone kept saying yeah begin to
feel so good when you do it when you get
up there and i can 100 say i went up
there and i did not feel good about
myself and i hated it i hated every
minute
uh i i get sweaty just thinking about
jumping off yeah it was awful but
that was a moment where i thought oh
maybe this is is too much for me to
handle
i could not have done uh that and i
could not have jumped off the building
like keanu like there's so much of this
movie like that um uh was there any
stuff that because i'm not going to talk
to lana was there any stuff that you did
that ended up not making the final cut
were there a lot of deleted scenes
um there aren't many deleted scenes but
you know what when we first started
filming in san francisco i wasn't on the
cool sheet for
like two three weeks
it was a lot of
a lot of the climax of the film with
another character
but i
wanted to absorb as much as i could so i
would just go to set every day and
i started just i started plugging myself
into the background as an extra
and the thing is tom hardy was filming
venom
too
down the road from us and so i got to
know him because we have a mutual friend
and i was like do you want to come be an
extra in
in the new matrix film so if you look
closely maybe you'll see me and tom
hardy running around in the background
uh that's amazing my last question for
you i am a big fan of the russo brothers
i know you're in gray man i'm obviously
a huge fan of ryan johnson knives out
what can you find about both of those
properties because i could not be more
excited about both
i mean
first off i just want to say i love
those guys so much all three of them um
ryan what can you expect from knives out
everything that you loved about the
first one but with a whole new cast of
characters except daniel craig of course
uh i mean it i i said yes to that film
so i could watch these actors go toe to
toe with one another it's daniel craig
edward norton kate hudson catherine hahn
leslie like
phenomenal cast and they're acting
right up here and i just wanted to be a
fly on the wall and with
the gray man yeah same thing phenomenal
cast the russo brothers are so
collaborative i think people are going
to love it i think people are going to
be surprised at the sense of humor it
brings
yeah i can't i can't wait for those to
come out
i yeah i got to stop there i'm just
going to say congrats on all your
success and i hope obviously matrix is a
huge hit
you